hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
another edition of enlightened by
intuitive eating so in our last video we
talked about principle number one reject
the diet mentality so if you haven't
watched that one yet definitely check it
out and then come back to see us here
today's video has been reviewed and
edited by my colleague Elissa Ramsay who
is an amazing intuitive eating dietician
so if you are looking for somebody to
work with one on one I'm gonna leave a
lot of information about Elissa her
website and Instagram definitely hit her
up she's amazing hey guys Switzerland
here I of course want to just jump in
here in flag that this content may not
be for all of my subscribers and that is
totally okay I want to spread the
intuitive eating message because I think
it's so amazing but I am in no way
prescribing this way of eating or
thinking at all so I just want to talk
about it you know what the research
suggests works and and what I've seen
work really well for people in practice
including for myself and if it works for
you amazing stick around we've got a
full kind of all of the different
principles to cover and if it doesn't
then I promise you there's a lot of
other great content here on Abbey's
kitchen that hopefully is a little bit
better suited to you and your goals now
in this video we're gonna be tackling
principle number two honor your hunger
and before we do I want to tackle a
question from one of my viewers so I'm
answering a viewer question every single
week so if you have a question
definitely leave me a comment below
before you forget your question and I'll
hopefully get to it in a future video
Dear Abby intuitive eating seems to work
under the assumption that a person is
binging as a result of restriction what
about for those of us who chronically
overeat and never restrict this is such
a great question now while it is true
that one of the best predictors of
overeating or binging is restriction
sometimes the experience is a little bit
more nuanced which is I think where the
disconnect lies even if you're eating
whatever you want consistently there's
often a restrictive mentality that is
the under threat of your relationship
with food so for example you might often
think things like oh I shouldn't have
that rice with those beans it's got too
much carbs I've already had one cupcake
so I might as well eat the whole bunch
or oh well I already blew my healthy
eating day I might as well eat an entire
pizza and start again tomorrow so even
if you're not physically starving
yourself and physically restricting
yourself the psychological sense of
scarcity can often have the same
biological response as actual physical
restriction what ends up happening is
our body goes into a natural survival
mode so your appetite increases your
preference for carb rich food increases
and your body basically fights to
prevent starvation at any cost even if
you're not physically starving my
colleague ELISA describes us beautifully
on her blog which I will link below and
she talks about the importance of moving
from a place of scarcity to a place of
abundance so we'll talk a little bit
about that as we go through this series
for sure another common reason for
overeating is distracted or mindless
eating so a lot of us like to keep our
mouths busy well maybe you're watching
TV or we're watching a movie often
either at a habit or sometimes out of
boredom so if we're distracted by the TV
or the computer what we have a big bowl
of food in our lap we may not really
notice how much we're eating until we're
at the bottom of the bowl and it's often
the case that you know we're just so
distracted and into the Batchelor rose
ceremony that we just cannot hear our
body's subtle signs and signals that has
had enough we will definitely be
touching more on this particular type of
mindfulness as we move through the
course another potential reason why
people might be overeating is because
they're consuming foods that are just
not physically or emotionally satisfying
diet foods are notorious for this a lot
of diet foods are really low in calories
and ultimately are just not that
enjoyable or pleasurable or satisfying
so we may eat a lot of them and still
feel like we need to eat more food to
fill the void sometimes this can be the
difference between fullness and
satisfaction my colleague Rachel hartley
put this beautifully and I'll link to
her blog she is amazing she said that
fullness is the physical sensation of
satiety
where satisfaction is the mental
sensation of satiety both here are
really important so if you're finding
that you're overeating a lot of these
health foods what you can do is try to
beef up your meal with some fiber
protein or fat in there for the fullness
factor and then something you love for
satisfaction so as an example if I were
to have like a green smoothie bowl which
is look
I'm glad I would need to add a little
bit of maybe some nut butter or some
seeds on top for the fullness factor and
then maybe some chocolate for the
satisfaction factor now I like really
want a green smoothie bulb there may
also be an over-reliance on food to fill
a lot of emotional needs and gaps and
that's something we're gonna be talking
about in this episode and ultimately
yeah something that is totally normal
and healthy to do because let's be real
it is normal and natural to celebrate a
birthday with cake even if you're not
physically really hungry for cake but
when we don't have any coping mechanisms
other than food this is really when we
need to seek out some counseling and
some help and some support to help us
get to the root of the issues okay so I
just want to jump in here and add one
more piece to the puzzle and that is
talking about the food scape that we
live in so a lot of people talk about an
obesogenic food environment that really
encompasses this idea that we have a lot
of higher calorie highly processed
highly palatable foods that not only are
lower in cost often than let's say
fruits and vegetables but also are just
readily available basically everywhere
we look so I think that that also may
potentially play a role as well if none
of these apply to you and you still feel
like you cannot stop eating then you
definitely want to speak to your health
care provider who may be able to run
some tests to be able to figure out if
there's something else going on
conditions like hypothyroidism insulin
related conditions like PCOS or
uncontrolled diabetes Graves disease
anxiety or depression or gastric
emptying can all increase feelings of
uncontrolled hunger so always always
always speak to your healthcare provider
to rule these things out now on that
note let's get to the meat and potatoes
of principle number two honoring your
hunger
hunger is a deep-seated natural
biological phenomenon that is designed
to help make sure that humans stay
fueled nourished alive and ultimately to
maintain their natural setpoint I have
talked a lot more about setpoint so you
can watch that in this video right here
so we actually listen to our body's
hunger and fullness cues we tend to eat
in ways that actually satisfy our body's
true biological needs in fact studies
done on intuitive eating
found that people tend to actually
balance out their food intake naturally
when they're not exerting external
pressures however when we ignore our
body's innate wisdom and instead follow
a set of rules like a diet to help
manipulate our weight our body will put
in place all of these mechanisms to
forcefully get us back on track here's
the thing our body cannot tell the
difference between a diet and a famine
in a panic our hunger hormones to
Grandpa our fullness hormones kind of
quiet and we obsess over food in an
effort to make sure that we hear those
messages loud and clear so while your
favorite wellness or fitness blogger may
claim that this is a lack of willpower
issue it's actually a biological drive
that is deeply embedded in our DNA
but what happens if you don't feel
hunger or you don't feel hunger until
you're literally starving let's talk
about some of the reasons why we may
feel disconnected from our body
number one numbing so instead of eating
whole meals a lot of dieters will try to
trick their body into thinking it's full
by like filling it up with a lot of low
calorie beverages like coffee tea at
least Lonnie's like cleanses celery
juice diet pop etc but all this really
does is kind of temporarily stretches
the gut and so it feels like there's
something in your belly but very quickly
you know you're gonna pee that out and
you're stuck feeling starving again soon
after and also on top of that feeling
distrustful in your relationship with
food number two dieting dieters become
very good at tuning hunger out if you
tune out hunger for long enough then
basically those signals just stop coming
and your body learns to operate on fewer
and fewer calories number three stress
so when we're stressed our body goes
into fight-or-flight mode so basically
all of our hunger cues are diverted to
allow our body to get ready for the
fight this is one of the big reasons why
people who go through major stresses in
their life tend to lose a lot of weight
unintentionally number four skipping
breakfast so a lot of dieters will skip
breakfast because it stops the hunger
wave from getting started
we need to shift the focus away from
believing that hunger is a bad thing and
instead recognizing it as a truly
essential biological drive and that is
also a really good sign that your
metabolism is actually working
and number five drugs of course things
like alcohol drugs smoking cigarettes
all of these can quiet that hunger queue
so if you are thinking about starting on
your intuitive eating journey this may
be a good time to kind of put those
vices on the back burner if any of these
experiences ring true to you you may be
wondering how the heck am I ever gonna
honor my hunger well let's get to it
if you've been dieting your whole life
it is very normal for you not to really
feel a whole lot of hunger so if that
sounds like you a really good rule of
thumb is to start by having three meals
plus snacks every single day and making
sure that you're eating regularly and
consistently throughout the day I also
want to acknowledge that yes I am
telling you that you may need to eat
even if you're not physically feeling
hungry know that this is just a
temporary step especially for those of
us who you know be dieting for so long
then we no longer can actually hear
those hunger cues but we need to train
the body to know that it can trust us
and the only way to do that is to eat
now once you start eating regularly
again you'll start to feel those hunger
cues kick in it's time to get acquainted
with your hunger and to do that I
usually like to use the hunger and
fullness scale so number one on the
scale is that you are starving you
absolutely need to eat like a SAP and
number ten it would be you're so full
that you pretty much feel sick most
people don't feel so great operating on
the fringes but you want to check in
with your hunger about one to two hours
after you eat go somewhere quiet so
wherever you are undisturbed put your
hand on your belly and breathe in
breathe out and just listen check-in if
you are not yet hungry then I want you
to check in again about thirty to sixty
minutes later to see if you're starting
to feel some of those early hunger
sensations now I want you to start to
take note of exactly how you feel at the
beginning of your meal
somewhere in the middle of your meal and
at the end of your meal so here are some
words that you can use to describe your
level of hunger either nothingness pain
aching tired or fatigued maybe you have
a headache
a burning sensation heart palpitations
growling stomach difficulty
concentrating lightheadedness you're
irritable etc now I will discuss this in
more detail when I get into the fullness
episode but I will say if you are going
through this exercise and you feel like
you just want to keep eating even though
you feel actually physically content or
full then you absolutely can I just want
you to notice it and notice how it makes
you feel and then move on intuitive
eating is not a set of hard and fast
rules sometimes are gonna eat to attend
because something tastes really really
good
and sometimes you're going to let
yourself get super hungry and then eat
super super fast and that is also a
hundred percent okay you didn't fail but
if you're truly listening it'll probably
mean that your body will need a little
bit more time before it needs to eat
again so in my video on intuitive eating
during my holiday I talked about how
sometimes I would eat too like a full on
ten because the only tastes really
really good or sometimes I would be
distracted and busy and I wouldn't hear
my hunger cues until they were screaming
at me and therefore I would eat a larger
meal but I didn't punish myself for not
honoring my hunger right I simply
noticed it I moved on and let my body
guide the way for the rest of the day so
really what you're doing is simply
banking information about how certain
foods or certain amounts of foods make
you feel and letting that information
inform the rest of your day week month
etc what do you mean doing this for a
little while start to take note of the
trends are you eating to complete
sickness all the time are you hungry all
the time
how many general hours before eating do
you get hungry again to certain foods
make you more hungry quicker than others
etc so for example some of you may like
more frequent smaller snacks or meals
while other people may like larger meals
further apart every body is different
everyone's needs are different so don't
go comparing yourself to other people's
diets finally I want to talk about
different types of hunger we tend to
always think about just physical hunger
but there's actually quite a lot of diff
reasons for eating all of which are
valid first is taste and mouth hunger so
like I mentioned in the question portion
of this episode some eyes we want to eat
something because something and it
tastes good or we're craving a specific
flavor or mouthfeel or maybe we're kind
of bored and it's been about a habit or
maybe you're on vacation and you really
want to try the food that that city is
known for and famous for you technically
may not be physically hungry but these
may be common reasons to eat anyways to
is emotional hunger so this is a really
common reason for eating and and once
you start to tune into your stomach
hunger you'll probably start to
recognize emotional hunger a lot louder
so emotional hunger is based off of
either positive or negative emotions so
it may be eating in response to sadness
or disappointment or on the flip side
eating in celebration well it's totally
okay to eat during these times it's also
important to know that food will not
solve your problems and ultimately we
need to find other coping mechanisms
that may be more helpful instead the
third is practical hunger so sometimes
you just have to be a little bit
practical when it comes to planning for
your meals and this also can fit within
the context of intuitive eating and I've
gotten lots of questions about this how
do you plan how do you meal prep and
also be intuitive so sometimes we know
that you know maybe I'm not hungry at
this minute but I'm not gonna be able to
eat again for another few hours and by
then I'll probably be hungry so you're
going to have a small snack or a small
meal in order to tide you over so you're
not starving and ravenous by the time
you can get to your next meal
you are still honoring your hunger even
if it is your future hunger and then
finally is stomach hunger now this is
that biological drive to eat because we
need those calories we need that fuel so
your stomach is growling you know maybe
you're feeling a little bit lightheaded
you're tired you're sluggish when it's
loud I get it's pretty obvious however
for some of you especially those who
have kind of dulled those signs through
dieting it can take a little bit of
practice to be able to pick up on those
subtle cues before eating I want you to
take a moment to try to get to the root
of what kind of hunger you're
experiencing and why are you wanting to
eat it's not wrong to eat out of
practical hunger emotional hunger or
taste hunger
I want you to be wary of turning
intuitive eating into you know the
hunger fullness diet which will just
pull us back into that onething
mentality which is so prevalent in diet
culture but the most important thing to
remember as you move forward on this
journey no matter what happens is to not
punish or shame yourself simply
acknowledge it and move on your homework
for this week is to use the hunger
fullness scale at every meal and snack I
want you to take note of where you are
on the scale at the beginning of your
meal
we need to pause part way through your
meal maybe once or even twice and then
of course also check in at the end of
your meal as well I want you to take
notes as you go being curious without
judgment so for example where there are
times where you didn't feel hunger until
you started eating and then you realized
hey actually you know I was actually
hungry are there times where you feel
some hunger but you don't eat if so how
come this is all just data so take it in
and look at it objectively like a
scientist without the moral lens and
remember if you're not feeling any
subtle hunger cues then before you get
started on this exercise I want to take
it back and I want you to start to make
sure that you're eating those three
meals plus snacks consistently and
regularly throughout the day to help
kick-start those hunger cues again
remember that intuitive eating
ultimately takes a lot of time to
embrace and to learn and it's all about
learning and respecting your bodies and
eat cues thank you again to my colleague
registered dietician Alissa Ramsey for
reviewing this episode I highly
recommend if you're looking for
registered dietician to check out her
website in the description below and
continue to work on these steps
throughout your intuitive eating journey
I'm gonna be following this up with
principle number three make peace with
food until then I would love to hear
some feedback from you guys so subscribe
to the channel leave me a comment below
with any questions that you have don't
forget i'm always gonna be answering one
reader question every single episode
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
[Music]